los despojos mortales de isabela 2a
reposan aquí en la catedral santiaguesa
de edimburgo y esta es la ocasión
también para los escoceses de venir a
rendir un último homenaje a su reina de
despedirse de ella muchos han hecho fila
desde muy tempranas obras desde las seis
de la mañana e incluso durante cinco o
seis horas han estado a lo largo de este
día esperando tener ese momento de
comunión con su reina de poder por fin
decirle adiós lo cierto es que y sabe la
segunda dejara tierras escocesas eso
será el día de mañana martes cuando
viaje su féretro a londres y lo hará en
un avión de la royal air force será un
viaje en el cual pues la princesa anna
estará acompañando ese féretro y luego
será trasladado a londres será llevado
al palacio de buckingham